wortschatz hobbys a1 b1 sport mein hobby
ist basketball spielen
mein hobby ist basketball spielen
ich spiele gern basketball
ich bringe mit dem ball
ich mache einen korb
ich habe einen korb gemacht
ich werfe einen pass ich habe einen pass
geworfen
ich ziele und werfe ich habe gezielt und
ich fange den ball
ich habe den ball gefangen
ich spiele gerne baseball ich mag
baseball
ich schlage
ich habe
den ball geschlagen ich fange den ball
ich habe den ball gefangen
ich schlage daneben ich habe dann eben
geschlagen
der baseballschläger
ich spiele mit dem baseballschläger
ich gehe ins stadion
ich bin ins stadion gegangen
ich bin g
in den bergen ich gehe gerne in die
berge
ich klettere werden
ich mag klettern ich klettere werden
ich mag klettern ich wandere gern ich
gehe gerne wandern
ich wandere gern ich gehe gerne wandern
ich fahre gern ski
ich gehe gerne skifahren
ich fahre gerne ski ich gehe gerne
skifahren
ich falle hin
ich bin hingefallen
ich falle hin ich bin hingefallen
ich fahre gerne wenn ich mag radfahren
ich fahre gerne wenn ich mal radfahren
ich jogge gerne ich renne gerne
ich mache
gerne krafttraining ich mache gerne
krafttraining
ich boxe gern ich gehe gerne boxen
ich mag seilspringen
ich war
ich gehe gerne baden
ich schwimme gerne ich gehe gerne
schwimmen
ich surfe gerne ich gehe gerne surfen
red
ich spiele
fussball ich schaue gerne fußball
ich schieße ein tor ich habe ein tor
geschossen
internet
mein hobby ist im internet surfen
ich surfe gerne im internet
ich schreibe viele e mails
ich habe viele e mails geschrieben
ich spiele videospiele
ich habe videospiele gespielt
ich checkte oft ich habe oft gechattet
ich höre musik und podcasts ich habe
musik und podcasts gehört
der musik und filme herunter ich habe
musik und filme herunter geladen
ich sehe filme und videos ich habe filme
und videos gesehen
ich bin auf facebook instagram und tik
tok
ich war auf facebook instagram und
tecdoc
spielen ich spiele gerne schach mein
lieblings spiel ist schach ich spiele
gerne karten
ich mag kartenspiele
ich spiele
art
ich spiele gerne fußball
da steht der tischfußball tisch ich
spiele gerne poker
ich gehe oft ins casino
ich spiele
spiele komm wir spielen ein brettspiel
ich spiele gerne billy art lasst uns
billard spielen gehen
ich mache gerne putz lässt ich mag putz
lässt
werde ein fan oder follower folgerung
hallo deutsche schule
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video